it appears while keen Phoenix is out to
leave a few patently unhappy faces on
the Warner Brothers bosses who financed
Joker though the film has danced its way
to nearly a billion dollars at the box
office since hitting theaters Phoenix
whose entrancing performance says the
deeply disturbed man behind the iconic
Batman villain that has driven much of
the film's success is reportedly not
quite as on board with a return
engagement as one might think if his
comments in a recent interview with the
Los Angeles Times are any indication his
participation in a potential Joker
sequel is far from a given the actor
explained I guess the fear was that
you'd get locked into doing something
repeatedly that you don't really care
about that doesn't motivate you or
excite you part of the whole attraction
to me of Joker was there was no
expectation I didn't sign a deal to do
more films it was a one-off I wouldn't
just do a sequel just because the first
movie is successful that's ridiculous
The Times interview comes a full month
after the release of Joker which has
become the highest-grossing r-rated
movie of all time is on track to join
the billion dollar movie club in the
very near future and is fully expected
to be a major player come award season
needless to say success like that has
led to a lot of talk around a franchise
obsessed Hollywood about whether or not
there will be a sequel to Joker Phoenix
who somehow managed to never appear in
any sort of sequel across a career of
nearly four decades has remained clear
that a return to the twisted mind of
Arthur Fleck isn't out of the question
but he's been just as adamant that it'll
take another truly compelling story to
get him to suit up for any Joker sequel
it's also pretty clear that's simply
flashing some extra green and Phoenix's
face will do the actor statement implies
he's definitely not in it just for the
money still he admitted that he had
talked a bit with Joker director Todd
Phillips about a follow up movie saying
long before the release or before we had
any idea if it would be successful we
talked about sequels in the second or
third week of shooting I was like Todd
can you start working on a sequel
there's way too much to explore it was
kind of in jest but not really
it seemed endless the possibilities and
wherever you go with the character the
actor went on to share that he'd even
gone so far as to make Mach posters for
a Joker follow-up
photoshopping the character into some of
the greatest movies of all time he
explained I basically said you could
take this character and put him in any
movie so I did a photo shoot with the
onset photographer and we made posters
where I photoshopped Joker into 10
classic movies Rosemary's Baby Raging
Bull Yentl if you see it you're like
yeah I'd watched that movie gentle with
Joker that would be amazing
director Todd Phillips seems equally
ambivalent about signing on for a
follow-up film in the same times piece
he insinuated that the fate of a joker
too may hinge entirely on the return of
both actor and director the director
admitted that they haven't talked much
about it at all
adding we've only talked about the fact
that if we ever did one and I'm not
saying we are because right now we're
not it couldn't just be this wild and
crazy movie about the Clown Prince of
Crime that just doesn't interest us I
think the reason why Joker is resonating
is what's going on underneath the movie
so many movies are about the spark and
this movie is about the powder if you
could capture that again in a real way
that would be interesting the real
question becomes whether or not Phoenix
and Phillips can find as much intrigue
in the explosion as they did in the
simmering fuse that is Joker
either way the fire is still burning for
more here's hoping that actor and
director can both find something
interesting in the flames check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bells
so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]